the mayor of kharkov says the city has
lost electricity and water supplies for
a second time in the past 24 hours
ukraine accuses russia of attacking a
power station that led to blackouts in
several areas on sunday night emergency
services had managed to restore 80
percent of it during the day but the
second largest city is still without
power
hannah celeste is the security studies
director at the think tank ukrainian
prison and she joins us now from athens
thanks very much for being with us first
of all could you just give us an idea of
what's actually happening on these
rapidly shifting front lines of this
ukrainian counter-offensive
surely for the last two weeks everybody
been expecting for the huge counter
offence on the south to liberate the
city of your son because most of the
long-range missiles that ukraine just
received from our partners being used
against the ammunition stockpiles there
however the ukrainian armed forces
started the counter-offense on the north
and that is fantastic even from our
perspective that within the three days
they managed to recapture to liberate
approximately two thousand square
kilometers in the uh kharkiv region just
at the border with the russian
federation those uh territories that the
russian armed forces have been trying to
take for approximately two months since
spring this year so as for now we see
that the fighting is continuing and we
see several tendencies first of all that
the russian armed forces are retreating
it's not withdrawal or regrouping as
announced on their moves
white is retreating because uh they are
leaving behind them a huge number of the
ammunition a huge number of the heavy
weapons and uh we now in real time
almost can follow the photos and videos
from those territories that they left
but also we have a huge number of uh
those russian armed forces who
surrendered and now we have plenty of
prisoners of poor not one too but we are
talking about hundreds and hundreds of
soldiers who just didn't want to fight
or those who were left without the
command because we have more and more
news that the russian leadership were
leaving the territories while the
soldiers were laughed by their own over
there um on the south as you said the
situation is much slower the reason is
that ukraine was not starting a
full-fledged operation or something like
this so it is more of the positioning
course if they attempt to take the
better position but to have two big
battles neither russian or ukraine are
capable as for now
they are rapidly taking land in the
northeast but as we've seen from the
russian example
holding that land is very different is
there an are there enough forces is
there enough strength to do that are
they capable of the gains they're making
they can maintain
i would say that there are three things
that we need to take into account first
of all is how locals are greeting
ukrainian armed forces so that is really
calling for the liberation and
these people will be happy to assist uh
both the administration and the military
to stay longer at this territory the
second uh issue is that if russians
would be able to fight they will fight
we know now about some villages on the
north east that they were left even
without any fight and locals were
putting the ukrainian flag by themselves
not waiting for the military so we see
that it is quite a low level of the
desire to fight for the territories from
the russian side and point number three
is that uh i if they will be able if
they are ready to fight they would not
target the critical infrastructure of
the civilian uh objects that's what's
happened uh you said about kharkiv but
yesterday the attack against the
electrical stations happened not only in
kharkiv but also in bipro and poltava uh
three other uh cities and you understand
that if you were as the fighter as the
armed forces are capable to fight and
ready to fight for these territories you
will fight at that cities you would not
start immediately just in a few hours to
charge it the civilian objects to make
as painful as possible uh for the people
of ukraine i think the russians in
bombing these these power stations
especially the one in kharkiv they're
showing that they've still got the
strength they're still a major major
force to be reckoned with aren't they
i would not to name them anymore the
second mighty army as they tried to uh
make the image and we already saw it
both from their capabilities from their
ability to fight and from
uh definitely the outdated equipment
that is not working as they were
promoting it another question is that
definitely they still have quite a
number of the long-range missiles they
are already not using the newest
sophisticated uh because there are a few
of them left but they have a lot of the
soviet data like s 300 that they are
using not against the airplanes that
they should but against the civilian
objects so yes ukraine is not so
euphoric we are very uh it's not only
pragmatic but let's say realistic we
understand what russia can do
but at the same time when we are pushing
them out of the ukrainian territory that
means that they have less possibility to
charge it with the artillery the cities
like kharkiv because some of those
villages that have been liberated within
the last week that is exactly when the
russian forces stationed the artillery
and how they targeted the residential
areas of parking so now the russians
will need to use a long-range missile
from the russian territory and that is
the capabilities that they are losing
with each day
great to get your insights there on the
situation happening in the east of
ukraine thanks very much